Okay. Now, we need to do some work
in the OfyService class, which is in the service
package. When you use Objectify to define an
entity class, you need to register the entity class.
You do this in the static method in
OfyService. See here, this is where we registered the
profile class. But you're going to need to go ahead,
and add the code to register the conference class.
You'll probably find that when you do that, you get an error. But the
error is quite simply because we don't have the right import, so go ahead and
import the conference class. And that's all
you have to do to register your entity.
Go ahead and pause the video for
a minute, while you register the conference class.